[Music]
so you can try
okay because in all my videos i always
say so now you know
so now you know because every time you
know like every time i make a video to
teach people something once you know you
can't unknow you will know it forever so
this is so now you try finally you get
to try it for yourself
where you are given a room and you're
given pieces of furniture and you get to
furnish it yourself of course instead of
giving you just an empty room there are
little challenges they're all the same
square right but they have there's
different labels this is a single
bedroom this is a playroom this is a
living room hub would you lay a living
room
it's like a little challenge for you how
how you would
position things that's why in all these
little stories i i try to use very um
relatable things like studio apartments
for a couple big room for siblings
through this people have been able to
like try to lay their own homes or they
appreciate that laying their own homes
is a form of design
and i wanted to use this as a way to let
people try that for themselves
and it looks like like logic but there's
a lot of design behind it it's it's very
um subjective there's no right or wrong
so
when people furnish their own bedrooms
or dorms or new apartments they are
participating in this act of design and
i wanted them to realize how important
that is design does not only come in
fancy forms like it's not only on design
magazines you see a nicely curated space
it comes in many forms like
even just choosing the color of your of
your plastic plates or the thing that
you cover your food with the basket
all these are designed
so do you think design is useful or
useless
i think it's totally useful it's not
that it's useful it's it's there it's
apparent it's like asking is eating
useful
you just do it you just eat you just you
just do it you like if you if i give you
an empty room and i give you a bit
you're the very act of
deciding where your bid goes is designed
[Music]